يجتمع مسؤولان أمريكيان رفيعا المستوى
مع مسؤولين سعوديين في الرياض اليوم حيث تسعى الولايات المتحدة إلى
التوصل إلى
اتفاق تطبيع محتمل بين المملكة العربية السعودية
وإسرائيل، وهي صفقة من شأنها أن تكون
رائدة لهذه المنطقة بالطبع،
أنا قادم إليك من
برمجة مارك الشرق الأوسط  المركز هنا في أبو ظبي الآن
المسؤولان هما بريت ماكغورك،
مسؤول مجلس الأمن القومي الأمريكي الذي يتمتع
بسنوات من الخبرة في الشرق الأوسط
وفي السياسة وباربرا ليف،
مساعدة وزير الخارجية لشؤون
المنطقة، وتأتي الاجتماعات بعد يوم من
زيارة مسؤولين فلسطينيين حسبما ورد
ستناقش المملكة مطالبها
من الإسرائيليين إذا مضى التطبيع مع
الرياض قدمًا، وفقًا
لصحيفة نيويورك تايمز.
وشدد مستشار الأمن القومي بالبيت الأبيض الآن على أن
الرحلة تركز على قضايا إقليمية أوسع
وليس مجرد صفقة تطبيع،
وسيكون التطبيع أحد أهم القضايا.  المواضيع المدرجة
على جدول الأعمال ولكنها ليست
المحور الرئيسي لهذه الرحلة وكما قلت
من قبل فيما يتعلق بالمكالمة الهاتفية التي
أجراها الوزير بلينكن اليوم، لا
نتوقع أي إعلانات أو
اختراقات وشيكة في الفترة المقبلة،
فنحن ندير التوقعات إلى حد كبير
سيدي  جيك سوليفان هناك يجيب على أسئلة
حول سبب الرحلة. الجزء الأكبر
من هذا التقرير يأتي من
زميلتي سي إن إن، السير كارلي أتوود، التي تنضم
إلي الآن على الهواء مباشرة من وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية
مع مزيد من التفاصيل ومن
المهم الإشارة هنا إلى أن
صفقة التطبيع هذه أن  الولايات المتحدة
متحمسة للغاية بشأن ما بين السعوديين
والإسرائيليين والذي من شأنه تمديد ما
يعرف باتفاق إبراهيم، كما
نفهمه كايلي كأحد ركائز
سياسة إدارة بايدن في الشرق الأوسط
للمضي قدمًا. جيك سوليفان هناك إدارة
كبيرة للتوقعات بشأن هذا
فماذا  هل نعلم في هذه المرحلة،
نعم حسنًا، بيكي، هناك الكثير من الأجزاء
حول ما يمكن أن يكون عليه
اتفاق التطبيع المحتمل بين المملكة العربية السعودية
وإسرائيل، وبسبب ذلك،
هناك عدد لا يصدق من
التعقيدات التي تدخل في هذا الأمر، فالأمر لا يتعلق
فقط بمعرفة الولايات المتحدة الجالسة  تجلس
مع المملكة العربية السعودية لتطوير مسار
للمضي قدمًا، لكن الولايات المتحدة أيضًا
تجلس مع إسرائيل لمعرفة ما
يمكن لإسرائيل أن تفعله، وتجلس
أيضًا مع الإسرائيليين لتكتشف ما يمكنهم فعله
للفلسطينيين للتأكد من أن
الفلسطينيين يشعرون أنهم يحصلون على ما يريدون.
شيء من هذا، كيف سيبدو
الاتفاق الأمني ​​بين الولايات المتحدة والمملكة العربية
السعودية كجزء من هذه
الخلفية أيضًا العلاقات السعودية الصينية
في الوقت الحالي، ما الذي يمكن أن تفعله الولايات المتحدة
للتقرب من المملكة العربية السعودية كجزء من
هذه الصفقة وسحبها؟
بعيدًا قليلاً عن الصين،
هناك الكثير من العناصر في هذا
وما نشهده هذا الأسبوع هو موجة
من الارتباطات التي يبدو أنها تشير إلى
أن الأمور تتحرك للأمام الآن
كما قلت، قال مستشار الأمن القومي
جيك سوليفان ذلك  هذه
الرحلة التي قام بها بريت ماكغورك من خلال اثنين من
كبار المسؤولين في إدارة
سياسة الشرق الأوسط في
مجلس الأمن القومي وفي
وزارة الخارجية، لا تتعلق رحلتهم إلى المملكة العربية السعودية
فقط بالحديث عن
إمكانية التوصل إلى اتفاق تطبيع
بين إسرائيل والمملكة العربية السعودية  لكنهم
أيضًا لا يقولون أن هذا ليس مدرجًا على
جدول الأعمال بشكل صحيح ولذا فنحن نعلم أن هذا
شيء
يركز عليه مسؤولو الإدارة بشكل خاص
في العام المقبل وما يمكن أن يكون
العام الأخير حقًا
لإدارة بايدن وهكذا.  من بين
الأجزاء الحاسمة في كل هذا كما
لاحظت، أن الفلسطينيين
منخرطون بالفعل في هذا الأمر، ففي
الجولة الأخيرة من
اتفاقيات التطبيع بموجب اتفاق إبراهيم،
لم يشاركوا حقًا، وكانوا محبطين،
وشعروا أن المشاركة لن تكون
مفيدة لهم.  وهم الآن
يرون أنه قد يكون هناك مجال لهم
لتحقيق شيء ما وفقًا
لصحيفة نيويورك تايمز، كما قلت إنهم كانوا
في المملكة العربية السعودية لعقد اجتماعات بالأمس في
اليوم السابق لوجود هذا الوفد من
المسؤولين الأمريكيين في المملكة العربية السعودية، لذا
هناك الكثير من الأجزاء في هذا الأمر، ولكن
يبدو أن هذه الموجة من المشاركة
يمكن أن تدفع الأمور إلى الأمام في
الوقت الحالي، نعم،
وأنت على حق في الإشارة إلى
ما يعنيه هذا بالنسبة للفلسطينيين
لأن المملكة العربية السعودية قالت بدون
مسار مستقبلي لـ  الفلسطينيون
لن يقوموا بالتطبيع
مع إسرائيل
أم نعلم أن وزير الخارجية
أنتوني بلينكن تحدث يوم الثلاثاء مع محمود
عباس الذي هو بالطبع رئيس
السلطة الفلسطينية، هل نعرف ما الذي
ناقشوه،
نعم لذلك أصدرت وزارة الخارجية
قراءة لتلك المكالمة  لم
تتحدث على الإطلاق عن
محادثة التطبيع بين إسرائيل والمملكة العربية
السعودية، لكنني أريد أن أقرأ لكم ما
أدرجوه في تلك القراءة قائلًا، نقلاً عن
بلينكن إكسبرس، القلق المستمر
بشأن العنف المستمر في الضفة الغربية،
وأكد مجددًا دعم الولايات المتحدة لإجراءات تهدف
إلى وقف إطلاق النار.  تعزيز الحرية والأمن
وتحسين نوعية الحياة
للشعب الفلسطيني، ناقش الوزير والرئيس
عباس دعمهما
لحل الدولتين ومعارضة
الإجراءات التي تعرض للخطر قابليته للتطبيق،
وهذه هي العبارة الرئيسية هناك معارضة
الإجراءات التي تعرض للخطر قابليته للحياة،
ويبدو أن  ربما تحاول الولايات المتحدة أن ترى
أنك تعرف ما الذي يريده الفلسطينيون
كجزء من اتفاقية التطبيع هذه،
وما هي الالتزامات التي سيطلبونها من إسرائيل
إذا كانوا سيعطون
الضوء الأخضر
ويسمحون للمملكة العربية السعودية بالمضي قدمًا أو يقدمون دعمهم لها.
بهذا
التطبيع